hi good afternoon everyone good
afternoon my name is Lin Cooley and I'm
very glad to have you here at our very
first company of scholars lecture for
the 2014-15 academic year this is the
16th year of our Dean's lecture series
in the Graduate School and it is
designed to bring students faculty staff
and community members together across
the disciplines to hear from our own
distinguished Yale alumni we get few
chances to do that I'm thrilled to carry
on this grad school tradition as the new
dean of the Graduate School
in addition today we have something very
special and a little unusual planned
instead of a lecture by a single faculty
member we have a team here Valery Hansen
Mary Miller and Anders Wynne Roth all
historians on the on the world circa
1000 the lecture is based on their
collaborative venture which is a
graduate course of the same name taught
this semester that leads students on a
remarkable tour of the world during the
Year 1000 when various regions of the
globe took part in complex social
economic and cultural networks across
continents Valeri Hansen is a professor
of history she started at Yale in 1993
her work focuses on medieval China
Chinese religious and legal history and
the history of the Silk Road her 2012
book the Silk Road a new history was
described as the most readable and
reliable historical account of the
fabled trade route that cut across the
center of Eurasia in medieval times Mary
Miller the sterling professor of history
of art specializes in the art of the
ancient new world her work on ancient
Mexico and the Maya garnered national
recognition including a Guggenheim
Fellowship she's elected to the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences in 1994 and
this academic year she'll be delivering
sleighed lectures at Cambridge
onder's win Roth is the first family
professor of history his work explores
the history of medieval Europe
particularly the religious intellectual
and legal history including the Viking
Age in 2003 onder's was named a
MacArthur Fellow for his work on the
development of medieval canon law as an
important antecedent to contemporary
legal reasoning thank you all for coming
to give us a glimpse of your combined
efforts in this class following the
lecture there will be plenty of time for
questions and then following questions
please join us in the common room which
is just adjacent for a reception so with
that I'll turn the podium over to our
speakers thank you all for coming the
plan for our 40-minute talk is a
30-month 39 minute plan each of us is
going to speak for 10 minutes and then
this in the same order so we're starting
in Asia so it starts with me then we
will go to Europe and Anders will take
over and then we'll go to the Americas
and Mary will take over and then after
we have each spoken for ten minutes we
will return in that order and each speak
for three minutes
the I was going to say we start I'd like
to start with and just say it's been
such a pleasure to teach with my
colleagues there have been extremely fun
and a lot of information has been on the
table all the time the in teaching the
course I realized that what we focus on
the year 1000 because so many of us
think of the age of exploration as
starting at a later date but in fact in
the year 1000 there are a lot of new
connections among different regions and
that's what we'll be talking about in
this talk the and looking at the map one
of the first things we did was ask the
students to draw a map of the world and
and and this is a you know given
projections and accurate map of the
world but one of the things that really
interests me is the formation of
different regions and how we define
these regions and which regions are
closer or farther
apart from each other not necessarily
just in terms of distance but also in
terms of ocean currents but I'm going to
start today I'm talking about
so my remit is Asia and in the year 1000
very simply a line is formed here
between China and then a northern
dynasty called the liao that governs a
lot this is a the grasslands across
Northeast Asia and this is a detailed
more detailed map of the liao they are
the liao dynasty and the coton people
and this purple area is the heart of the
empire where their Imperial tombs are
the this is one of the rare pictures we
have of the liao that doesn't barbarian
eyes them and maybe it's a copy a later
copy of a painting by a Keeton painter
and the Keaton and the song the liao and
the sung had a series of battles in
throughout the 10th century and then in
a thousand and four the Keaton won a
resounding victory over the sung and
they drew up a treaty between the two
powers the Chinese and the Keaton called
the Treaty of China and in according to
which the Chinese agreed to pay a
hundred thousand taels of silver so
that's a tale of silver that's actually
50 taels of silver
it's a you at 50 ounces of silver and
then two hundred thousand bolts of silk
the euphemism in the treaty was to help
with military expenses but this was
because the son had lost and that treaty
really draws a line between the Chinese
and the coton territory there's and
there are agreements about there are
markets set up on the border and certain
goods are not supposed to be traded some
recent work shows that the border is
permeable it's not as fixed as we once
thought but in fact the Keaton are
oriented north and west and the summary
and war reorient
to the Southeast Asia and import a lot
of goods actually a lot of strange
fragrances like ambergris um things we
know from the Bible and myrrh and
frankincense so and the diplomacy at
this time some of the people who are
moving the farthest between among
different regions are envoys and we have
a written record on the Chinese side of
about the movement of envoys among
different places and the Keaton's making
an effort to sign is to form a race of
sorry to establish a relationship with
Islamic dynasty to the West in what's
now Afghanistan the Keaton have their
own written language we can barely read
it so almost everything we know we know
from Chinese sources or from
archaeological sources and this is an
imperial tomb of a princess who died in
1018 it's the only Kiton tomb that was
not disturbed and you can see some of
the goods that the luxury goods that
were valued by the Keaton which in the
course we call bling and the and I've
got an arrow on the amber the amber is
very important so the good some of the
goods from this tomb dated 1018 then
Keaton territory in that purple area I
showed you at the beginning we've got
glass this is all of these things are
from the Islamic world so a glass bottle
probably from Egypt or Syria a rock
crystal bowl that is very small a plate
a metal plate with motifs on it that we
can match other plates that have been
found in Neesha por Iran and the nice
report was under the rule of the Gus new
vids
that's this dynasty that was in
Afghanistan and into some of Iran and
the guns new vids the Leo decide that
the Keaton's were up here decide to try
to form a diplomatic relationship with
the ghaznavids they send an envoy and we
know about this because an Islamic
geographer named marvadi tells us about
this and he
tells us that the envoy the gifts that
the envoy presented to the ghaznavids so
silk clothing sable furs the Leal were
had a lot of access to furs of North
Asia musk and then a bow with ten arrows
which was a symbolic gift of
establishing an allied relationship and
the ghaznavids replies and says this
that there's no faith uniting us
basically you are not Muslim and we are
and because you're so far away from us
we're safe they're protected distance
protects us from perfidy I have no need
of close relations with you until you
accept Islam and that is all so the I
was gonna say so
oh oh it's funny on my on Mary's
computer this debate is blank this is a
map of the Islamic world and this is so
in my part of the talk I want to
establish three regions or sketch three
regions the layout territory
the song territory and then the very
large Islamic world in the center and
this is a map from a cup it's a copy of
a map of an Islamic map from the 11 50s
and it shows you the extent of the world
known to Islamic geographers and they
knew more about the world than anybody
else at this time in the year 1000 the
and one that same Islamic geographer
Marv Ozzie who told us about the and the
diplomatic attempt for by the liao to
establish relations with the Gustav it's
also reports that the main goods going
from the Islamic world to the Chinese
and presumably the Liao were ivory
frankincense and genuine Slavonic amber
and then who - who - is a word that this
is my transition to unders this Slavonic
amber amber has actually been tested
chemically that this is nothing well
some of the amber from Liao tombs and it
turns out it is actually from the Baltic
and then the who - is walrus tusk and
that is one of the things linked
East Asia and North Asia with the parts
with Europe and with that unders you're
on thank you so Lee our princesses Scott
amber from the Baltic Sea the rulers of
Northern Europe also got things from
China and from the Far East
this silk cuff found in a Swedish Viking
Age grave does not come from silk made
in China but assigment made in the
Middle East but there are other less
photogenic silk elsewhere in the graves
that at least European textile
historians think was woven in China
well the Valerie tells me that Chinese
textile historians do not agree how did
this get to all the way to Northern
Europe let me tell you another story
this is about a not very ordinary school
class that was camping out in 1975 on
the island the swedish island of Gotland
in the Baltic Sea I'm sorry I wasn't
there I wasn't old enough by that time
they had been studying Viking history
for several months and as a grand
finale' they were doing this real
experience living like Vikings out in
nature they picked a good place a place
with mysterious ancient monuments a
place that according to local lore was
where the Viking chieftains Stav are had
once hid his huge very valuable treasure
they had a very enjoyable time the last
morning they performed sacrifices in
front of an old bouta stone they
sacrificed smoked smoked perch flowers
that they had picked pottery that they
had made and prayed that the gods in
return would give them money they needed
money and they wanted to go to Denmark
the bus that was going to pick them up
was late they packed everything up they
cleaned up they were waiting that
nothing to do was a beautiful Swedish
high summer's day they rested they were
relaxed they saw a rabbit scurrying
around on the meadow and they thought
let's catch it so they ran after it but
this was not a stupid rabbit this was a
Swedish rabbit sweet of course ran down
into his burrow
one of the most intrepid boys in the
class put his arm down the barrel would
it be bitten by the rabbit or would he
pull the rabbit out by its ears well
when he pulled the arm out he pulled out
something considerably more interesting
a coin an old coin with an inscription
that nobody could read they called the
local museum which immediately sent
archeologists that excavated the rabbits
burrow and found 1452 silver corns that
have been put there at the middle of the
10th century little before the year
thousand most of them were Arab silver
coin from the Caliphate at the other end
of Europe how did they get there to
begin to answer that question I want to
tell you a third story bulgur at the
very least of Europe on the Volga was a
was a great market town in the early
10th century it was the capital of the
bull gars who had recently arrived they
were ruled by ruler called al mish even
silky Gill tomorrow he had decided that
they needed to become Muslim so he had
let the Caliph in Baghdad know about
that the Caliph santim diplomatic
mission to bulgor to convert them we
know about this because one of the
participants of the mission
a man called Ahmed in fat lon
wrote a report about it which has been
preserved in an Iranian library in fat
LOM tells us that the trip there took
almost a year from Baghdad to Bulgari
but he also tells us a lot about what he
saw in Bulgari wasn't no Alert observer
very curious about two strange habits of
this far far away people he tells us a
particular about a part but a group of
merchants who were riding boats on the
Volga Roos merchants historians fight
about who the roots were but most agree
nowadays that they at least were
partially made up of Scandinavians he
tells us about the ruse that when they
arrived from their territory to Bulgari
they disembark and the first thing they
do is to go out to a great pole set in
the ground that at the top of it as a
face like the face of a man in front of
the pole they prostrate themselves and
pray to their gods they say in furlan
tells us my lord I had come from a
faraway country and I'm bringing to you
and bringing here so and so much fur
priced at such as such a pelt and so and
so many slave girls priced at
such-and-such per head and I implore you
to bring me a wealthy merchant with a
lot of dinars Arab silver Arab gold
cords and a lot of Durham's
Arab silver coins who will pay me what I
asked
without haggling
the story tells us about one of the
links in the great trade and exchanged
networks that brought dear M's and cilix
to Scandinavia slaves and fur to to the
Middle East and amber to China the Arab
Caliphate is one of the two great
empires of the Mediterranean this time
Mediterranean culture and religion
expanded greatly around the year
thousand Christianity making it to
northern northern Europe to Eastern
Europe Islam making it to the eastern
Russia to Central Asia even to India and
also to sub-saharan Africa all in the
long year thousand that is the period we
teach in this class the kingdom of Mali
in the Sahel south of of the of the
Sahara was not only the place that
supplied Europe and and the Arab world
with most of its gold
it was also an area that converted to
Islam in the 11th century the cultures
of the Mediterranean pushed out in all
directions most distantly to Greenland
which was saddled just before the year
thousand by a small group of
Scandinavians
it's a beautiful gorgeous place to live
wouldn't you like to move there I can
send you know these are their these are
the foundations of their houses it's
gorgeous but and there's plenty of green
grass where you can feed leave livestock
for the short summer the winter is long
and it's coming soon and those icebergs
might be pretty but they're not going to
feed you so why did they move there
well the ocean had riches fish of course
but also walruses their tusks can be
polished and carved and looked very much
like elephant ivory and sold at great
prices certainly in Europe I mean now
found out also in shine now though
probably not be
your walrus tusks from from Greenland
now green that has another disadvantage
for if you want to sell if you want to
ship walrus tusks orbital Europe
no trees grows there grower there is too
cold you can't build boats but the
Greenland has quickly learned that there
was wood on the other side in North
America Labrador is heavily forested
just before the year thousand they
started to go there they even built a
settlement at the northern spot of
Newfoundland enhancer Meadows which has
been excavated this is a reconstruction
of wonder that their turf houses built
in just around the year thousand and so
Meadows proves that Scandinavians lived
in North America during the Middle Ages
it also gives us fascinating hints about
further excursions there are butter nuts
in this settlement butter nuts don't
grow in Newfoundland only south of the
Gulf of st. Lawrence so we know that the
Scandinavians there got them either by
trading with American Indians or by
going even further south to get them
themselves and I wonder Mary how far
south do you think they got
well we step on to the Americas I see
all these people standing at the back
there are a few scattered seats up here
in front if you're miserable you can you
can find chairs um
I want to thank Lynn and the Graduate
School for making it possible for us to
continue on our voyage today in the long
year 1000 and just to make perfectly
clear what is the long year 1000 we
talked about the long the long 19th
century
well we've expanded this a little bit
longer given how slowly time might have
moved to think of this from 800 to 1200
but we turn to it turns it may very well
be and onder's and I are now embarking
on a little investigation of the
evidence that may or may not in the end
tell us that there were Norseman who got
all the way not only did they not like
icebergs in the winter unders but they
wanted to go to Yucatan and see what is
there with this rather a strange ship
that looms up in a fragment at chichen
itza from just the long year 1000 this
long year 1000 we look at rather
differently in the americas for the
connections here and if we go back and
think about the currents and what the
oceans do for us they in fact the
currents of along the South American
coast are ice cold and make it almost
make it impenetrable in many ways to
cross the Pacific and so there's little
evidence there's periodic evidence for
some stray contacts but not the kind of
sustained trade nor the writing in most
places that allows us to see it but it
is these we have addressed ourselves
over the course of the semester and
created in creating assignments for our
students I'm happy to see some of them
are here today
the 21 graduate students from nine
departments and programs who are
enrolled in this class we have
challenged our students to think about
what is the nature of knowledge how is
it stored and communicated whether we're
in the Andes or how is it that certain
materials become the privileged ones how
is it that the textile primacy of the
Andes emerges and what do we do in a
world without Garrety without certain
kinds of domestic animals that we find
that we expect so much well we depend
heavily on archeology and from the Andes
it has been really a time of great
riches in understanding the worry whom
we can just wrap in two-hour long year
1000 where there have been stunning
discoveries finally the kinds of
discoveries that make it possible for us
to imagine some of the loot that was by
and large sacked from these cities or we
can turn to the north coast and we can
see these great Adobe cities
changjun probably one of the largest
cities in the new world in the year 1000
and where some of the longest textiles
of the world have been retrieved we've
assigned our students in fact two weeks
ago we had quite a feast when we
assigned to them the challenge of
preparing not only the possibility of
the feast of the Year 1000 from three
parts of the world but also the daily
peasant food and as well as what is
eaten in the time of famine and it turns
out that famine and feast are sometimes
the same because of the amount of Labor
that it takes to get those termite eggs
for example that might be both will step
north from the Andes and just continue
our our food tour to the maize based
diet that would transfer
the world and as we had our students
look at the questions of what these
wonderful what the wonderful meals were
in the year 1000 how subsequently some
of these fundamental plant stuffs would
change the diet of the entire world
especially in the time of the discovery
of the Americas we looked at the way the
tools and transportation and materials
change the world or not we had robust
discussions in our class about the
problem of the absence of the wheel in
the Americas except for its use as a toy
as you see here and what that means when
you're making anything from pulley and
making a building to weather when you
are making ceramics we have we talked
about the the challenges of games what
the world games were like in the world
with before the discovery of the rubber
of the Americas and really focused in on
the absence of team sports by and large
until that moment we turned in
particular than in Mesoamerica to the
great period of toltec domination which
comes about at the north of Yucatan and
north of Mexico City in two great cities
Tula and chichen after the collapse
around the year 800 of the great Maya
cities of the south and this is kind of
a heartbreaking moment because this is
when we lose all the data this is when
writing really stops being so widespread
and so we don't have we can find
fine-grained historical data day by day
blow-by-blow accounts before the Year
800 and not easily afterwards but we do
now have the strong sense of one
particular ruler at Chichen itzá a ruler
named Kaku Kaku Paco
who for the later 9th and early 10th
century was instrumental in the major
constructions of Chichen Itza
and it's from it's in this moment 900 to
1100 when things begin to get really
really interesting and we see
Mesoamerica at its greatest wingspan as
we turn naught and find that it is the
turquoise that is coming from New Mexico
and the gold that is coming from lower
Central America all finding its way to
both Tula and to Chichen itzá Tula here
a great northern city and it is from
here then that we realize and can
understand the connections all the way
to the American Southwest we're in the
same mines that today yield principally
turquoise they were fertile places for
gold and silver in the early years of
Spanish domination of the American
Southwest and also pre-hispanic times
and around the Year 1000 not much of it
gold and silver are not of much interest
it is the powerful powerful blue-green
stone that we see here and that in fact
is what can be mined today how else do
we see these connections for surely the
turquoise in the all across Mesoamerica
is emblematic of that contact to the
American Southwest
well here's what's new in recent years
the discovery by taking the samples of
the pots that were excavated in the 19th
century and that are at the Museum of
American American Museum of Natural
History today that there's chocolate in
these pots in the American Southwest and
it's tropical chocolate that was grown
down in the Maya region and sent to the
great city of Pueblo Bonito
in Chaco Canyon that perhaps many of you
visited on your drives across the United
States
finally it takes us in the year 1000 and
is there anyone here from the state of
Illinois have you been to Cahokia good
so the sense of the year 1000 Cahokia
was a city of 50,000 it was the largest
city north of chichén itzá
in this in this period it is perhaps
where we'll end right now as we come
back in our year 1000 closing our loop
as close to us as we can come in this
class so I would like to just say that
in the experience of teaching with
Marian Anders and thinking about what
makes the world of in the year 1000
different from the world later or
earlier that one of the differences that
we noticed I think Mary noticed was that
there were no new religions after the
Year 1000 and then people in the class
would say of course what about Mormonism
what about Sikhism but and there but
these are these the new religions the
religions that take shape after the year
1000 are remixes of older of religions
that exist and what's very striking
about the year 1000 is that even though
there's no new technology so the
different forms of transportation that
people are using they're walking they're
using wheeled carts they're using wooden
boats in some places they have sails in
some places they don't the news of the
major religions spreads throughout the
old world not not the world we've almost
everything we said all semester long
we'd say oh but not not the Americas the
and so in the year 1000 there are
several famous conversions unders
mentioned one of the kazars who convert
to Islam the bull gars convert to
Judaism the Kiev Roose convert to
Eastern Orthodox religions apparently
struck by the beauty of Hagia Sophia in
Constantinople and that I think is one
of the things that's new about the year
1000 is this knowledge of a much larger
world and if you count the nor we the
Scandinavians they even know about the
Americas
so that is the I guess the main thing I
have learned so far it's been very
refreshing to teach a course in in
conjunction with two such great teachers
and I have learned a lot from the course
we have discussed one of the things we
discussed early on is how do you what
assignments do you give at the end of
the semester to our students we
discussed a lot at how we when we teach
graduate courses have a tendency to give
the standard assignment of a long
research paper 2013 even more pages
something that I guess in some kind of
ideal world is supposed to mimic the
journal article but who writes three or
four journal articles in one month we
certainly are not capable of that we
thought of using this course as a way to
think of new ways not only a new ways of
teaching but also new ways of assessing
student outcomes so we designed some -
some of us at least unusual assignments
at the end of the term and during the
term I just give you two examples one of
them is what we had yesterday when each
of our 21 students had been was
presenting their curatorial stalks on an
exhibit or a small part of an exhibit on
the year thousand that had organized in
the Museum of circa 1000 that we hope to
build as soon as we can get enough money
but so the students used a program where
you can lay out an exhibit and then they
have to decide what is the theme of my
corner of this museum what do I need to
say on the labels that are in the
exhibit cases how detail do they shall
they bleep be what is useful to convey
what I want to convey with this exhibit
we had this all yesterday we managed to
get 21 students there giving talks all
in
less than one hour and fifty minutes
much thanks to me being a real martinet
about timekeeping when for which I
apologize we also ask our students to
design an undergraduate syllabus for a
course on a theme coming out of this
course that they would like to teach if
they're becoming professors of the
college we are particularly excited
about that since the three of us have
decided to offer a similar course as an
undergraduate course for the spring
semester of next academic year we are
thus excited to read our students
syllabi we are excited to see our
students teaching these kinds of courses
when they go out on on the job market
and when they go out and get jobs
something that we also think would serve
them very well on the job market to be
able to bring this syllabi Mary I'm
running the the anchor leg here as part
of this trio when Lynne introduced me
she introduced me as a historian it's
very I kind of thinking it's exciting
I'm historian up I will say that I have
felt like a historian this semester but
I have also felt very much that I've had
the opportunity to make art historians
of my colleagues in the history
department and I think this is the kind
of outcome that when a few years ago I
began thinking about and then
subsequently applied to the mellon
Foundation for a grant on reimagining
the humanities at Yale and so we started
our class in the museum the Yale
University art gallery we went to the
Metropolitan for a day and we end with
the virtual Museum of our class and then
a visit to the by Nikki when we come
back after Thanksgiving but we have
depended so closely all semester on the
intense reading of a few things we know
you can't possibly know
the Year 1000 when you walk out of this
semester but we hope that each week as
we have sent our students off to think
about particular new new challenges that
they do have that sense of the the way
that the thing can inform their thinking
this has in fact this semester given me
a lot of thought now newly back I feel a
little bit like Rip Van Winkle or brand
new appointee to the faculty after years
in the in SSS but the way that how do
our students come to knowledge now did
they start by reading a book do they
start by googling around do they look at
the pictures how do we in fact think
about where humanistic knowledge lies in
the era of what I would call a kind of
visual democracy that never existed
before in the past you used to have to
wait for that special seeing a
seeing-eye guide dog known as an art
historian to take you in to the museum
to help you find those pictures and
that's not the case anymore so how can
we make our teaching and inform our
assignments more deeply with with the
visual that is one of the things I've
learned I've also learned about the
isolation of the world of the Americas
before the Year 1000 it has been painful
to see how isolated before the Spanish
invasion of the new world how cut off it
is especially even in North even in the
United States and so I have recommitted
myself to this feeling that it is one
year one thousand one very long year and
it we look forward to promulgating this
knowledge further in the future thank
you
one of the things this semester is we
constantly unders complains about or
said he was the martinet yesterday we've
all had turns as the martinet and so we
are keen on timekeeping and that's why
we have lots of time for questions
where is Cahokia it's it's a great state
park Valerie you worked at Cahokia
perhaps you would like to describe your
first paying job it's an East st. Louis
so yeah not too far from Crawford
Crawfordsville this the wait I'm
blanking on the name of the town where
all the riots have been Ferguson
Ferguson sorry Ferguson it's a and it
was my first paying job as a ivory
enacted Mississippi and Indian life and
made these stupendous sum of $100 a week
and there are incredible dig area types
of the destruction of much larger mounds
in East st. Louis in the 1860s it was
really a tragedy the destruction of this
of the vast range of the site yes Doug
how long is the long year and does it
vary between regions
it's as long as we need it to be as
every long century but we have for the
purpose of the course we have defined it
as 800 to 1200 but the closer you get
the better it's of course a lot of us
when you work with written documents
then you can date things often more
precisely than when you work with
archaeological documents that we all
three have worked with both kinds of
documentation so the question is whether
what was the year 1000 in terms of say
the traditional notion in which this is
often viewed as a kind of nadir of
cultural excitement I think we would all
say that well I'll certainly say from
the point of the new world
Cahokia will go on into the 13th century
Chaco Canyon is absolutely at its peak
this is the era of the Toltecs the this
incredible connections these are really
thrilling times in the new world and so
perhaps your history course was simply
lacking well it is true I often in my
undergraduate survey course on on
Western European history I present the
10th century as the ion century the
essential when you did not want to be
alive I think you didn't want really to
be alive in any century before the 20th
because it was things were terrible but
but it is true that it it is it is an
order both in both in Western Europe in
Byzantium and in Islam things are going
down but that's also that's where the
house is about the time when you have
the Colonels
new growth in all these areas in Europe
that's when it all starts that when
Europe takes off for gathering for
instance I was only gonna say that many
years ago Anderson I taught a course in
the history department about the
medieval transformation of China and
Europe and pretty much the whole
semester I would say to Anders and when
did X happen and he would say starting
in the year 1000 and so the year 1000 is
more of a date in European history than
it is in the other regions up yes in the
back no that's you Midway yes so the
question is what do we think is the
benefit of looking at history through
this band of time around the globe I
mean I a lot of world history is
impossible to teach because you're
trying to do so much and a lot of
historians focus on one part of the
world usually based on whatever
languages they can read so I think by
focusing on a single time as opposed to
a single space you can get around the
globe with some some complexity so I
think it's a good alternative to the
stock narratives of X nation's history
and I also think it's in order to
understand any given nation's history
you need to know what was going on
around the world at that time and I
think that was a key motive motive
motivation for all of us I guess one of
the things that we've also found that's
really been beneficial is that it's very
clear to each of us that our own
knowledge of the Year 1000 only goes so
far and we hit this preps precipice and
we go right over it and explore new
areas because no matter how much we know
we don't know everything about the year
1000 we couldn't possibly and I think
it's been useful our students might beg
to differ
but I think it's been useful to model
for our students that in fact you don't
know everything when you're teaching you
have to go find the answers you
sometimes have to just say I don't know
that and come back and find things out
and figure out how you're going to come
up with that piece of knowledge it's
been one of the features of our
assignments is there is not only what is
the answer but how would you get to that
answer
right here in front the question is
whether there is a place for genetics in
our studies I mean there is we have
talked about haven't talked about it
very much in this course but it is
something that that not being a
geneticist myself and not understanding
the studies I have read several studies
of the genetics of European population
populations in and I hope I've been able
to draw responsible conclusions from
what I've been reading we have shared
some of that in this course but nobody
really took that theme and ran with it
so far far back on the on the left my
left yeah that's you
so the question is how did we deal with
questions of social and political
organization I'll just say that one of
the first things we read was the 19th
century foundational document on that
was written to imagine what social and
political organization would be among
Native Americans and other non-western
peoples by Lewis Henry Morgan in which
he lays out the framework that all
people should be able to be sorted into
savage barbaric and civilized mark I
feel like we should answer your question
hmm I think to tell you the truth that
most of the time we got by with a
shorthand of are these upper strata
medium strata lower strata because we
were really looking at the connections
among different places and much less and
that changes the internal changes in
occurring in those places we did also
when we when we planned the course we
decided to organize the syllabus around
a different fee in each week so we have
had the theme of bling we have the theme
of food we had the field of transport we
had the theme of calendars shall I see
challenges that meets every civilization
on earth whether they know of each other
or not everybody has to eat and so forth
and one of the themes that we discussed
as possible one was was rulership and
kingship and such but it by then there's
only 13 weeks to the semester so so we
couldn't do it we do have the last class
is the discussion what is missing from
the syllabus and I just gave those
students are here one of the answers I
think should be there Paola
the question is what happened in class
and how did the assignments map onto the
intellectual goals a lot of things
happen in class you should ask our
students yes we we try to vary what we
were doing in class as I said yesterday
we had 21 presentation at a maximum of
four minutes not four minutes in two
seconds four minutes earlier in earlier
times we have had each of us have given
a lecture on the year thousand in the
region that we know best which
apparently in my case includes Africa so
I had to go out and read some basic
textbooks other other classes we have
had group presentations the students
have been pursuing themes outside of
class as groups most of the work in the
class is of course done outside the
actual class time so that it is start
for I hope you answer your question I
would say that one of our goals was for
students to gain depth in familiar
cultural areas and to gain breadth in
unfamiliar ones so we have constantly
had what we would call the remix of the
students and we've even been insistent
we used place cards so that they could
not sit in the same comfortable seats so
to try to keep unsettling the comfort
zone has be given how uncomfortable we
were
Rey fair the question is did we consider
the role of slavery it's an important
it's an important facet of history that
we certainly discussed we didn't devote
any particular theme to it it's it's
it's we the themes that we did for the
different classes tend to us to avoid
the more well slavery stuff not slavery
as such a word is an abstract word they
try to avoid that we we did we did touch
upon it several times as I even did in
in the lecture now know uh how are we
doing on time Lin are we doing okay okay
James the question is if I can try to
rephrase it James from one of our
students in the class did the course
develop as out of interest of ours in
the history or out of the pedagogy that
we might develop and regardless of which
how we answer that
how will it differ from the
undergraduate class valerie i feel that
you suggested this class to me so
perhaps i we were in a meeting and well
i i think of the three of us I'm the one
who's crazy enough to think you can
learn enough about the world 1000 the
world in the year 1000 to write a book
about it and so we started off I think
with the subject matter and then I think
the big change between a graduate and
undergraduate class will be
so many of the assignments were asking
you how to do things and and setting I
mean our goal was to give you a bigger
toolkit than you might have the students
in different departments might have
coming in to graduate school I think
with the undergraduates the goal isn't
going to be so much developing a
graduate student toolkit
I think the assignments may be more
tailored I don't know we haven't we
haven't gotten to the undergraduate
course yet and I would say one thing is
that every student including the two
undergraduates who are among the 21
brought real expertise in some part of
the world in the year 1000 to the table
and we won't expect that with
undergraduates and that's why we're
really going to have to rethink what we
do Jenny so Jenny Frederick's would like
to know how our students feel about all
this well they're not done yet and then
what are what was the second part of the
question what are would we recommend
these creative assignments to our
colleagues I think yes I mean it's it's
I mean this ties into James question -
did we do this for pedagogy or for
subject matter we do it for both of
course and I certainly feel that I
learned a lot about subject matter and I
learned probably then more about
pedagogy the the I think I think we do
well as professor to vary assignments
just as assessment assignments just as
we do well in wearing varying the
methods of instructions that we use and
for us it has been a laboratory to learn
about this because we have different
teachings now it's the three of us and
we learn from each other and we hope our
students are learning from it as well
and maybe none of this is is none of the
assessments and so forth are brilliant
inventions that we came up with in the
last few months these are methods that
are used across
that's by others of our colleagues and
we have looked at what other people have
used and try to use it as well here in
front the question is what is what what
are what is our final assessment there
were two final assignments one was using
Sketchup to make a museum case of six to
ten objects or pictures from more than
one region in the world in the year 1000
and then the other time and that
assignment had many components making
the case I think I was profoundly
relieved I did not have to make a case
using Sketchup software took a long time
to learn writing an essay about their
case writing labels for the case writing
text for the wall introducing the case
and then the undergraduate syllabus
those are the two main these are third
also in that as we asked those students
to review the museum as a whole to write
a review of not only their own exhibit
case but all of the exhibit cases as
conceived of as a museum altogether okay
one more question you've had your hand
up a long time
the question is uh what happened in the
far southern latitudes especially given
all of that emphasis on Greenland so in
the year 1000 there are some connections
that you can see of the wari down below
down beyond Peru and into northern Chile
but it would be very modest in terms of
what what we would find that connects to
one of the Grand cultures that would be
focused in the central Andes so we
couldn't do everything that would be my
explanation for the Americas it's not as
though there are not people living there
but where we have the kind of durability
and works that were imbued with meaning
by their makers that gives us some
possibility of making an intelligent
discussion and comparison of those works
we did decide early on that we would
skip Australia altogether we were
already feeling as though we were at the
absolute limits of our that we were
constantly going over the precipices of
our knowledge as it was I was gonna say
one of the first assignments asked the
students to collect materials in their
own field of study and then also to
choose a field that was new to them and
develop a bibliography about that part
of the world in the year 1000 and one of
the students who is from Slovak from
Russian and East European and a student
he did Australia for his sample and I
remember saying to him well what
happened in the year 1000 and he said of
course you know the humans get to
Australia in 40,000 BC so that's the
start date but he said the there are
people here who will correct me I hope
is there something like the super large
marsupials anyway so there's some
category of animal in Australia that
dies out in the year 1000 and and New
Zealand is settled for the first time in
1350 so it's a it's on the to-do list
I'm told we're gonna continue the theme
of global interconnectedness at the
reception where we're going to have some
food from different parts of the world
so I encourage you to come join us there
and I just want to say thank you